كنت خارجه يعني العب سايكنج قبل البطوله
اول بطوله اللي كنت مفروض اشارك فيها
وضربتني سياره بس اهم شيء انك لما تطيح
بتعرف تقف
[موسيقى]
دكتوره ساره الاجنف عمري 33 سنه مقيمه في
الامارات من عشر سنوات
بدايتي مع الرياضه مع السباحه بشكل خاص
كان عمري اربع سنوات
وبديتها في تونس مع اخوي الكبير واسامه
وبديت رحلتي مع السباحه من من وقتها يعني
سنه
1994 رياضه كانت على طول عشقي وحبي من انا
صغيره يعني
وانا صغيره لكن ما كنتش حابه اتخصص في
الرياضه في دراستي يعني كنت حابه على طول
اخليها هي شغفي وهي حبي لكن كرياضه مش
كشغل بس لما درست درست علوم سياسيه في
امريكا تخصصت في العمر السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه وبعد درست تجاره دوليه لكن في
الاخر لفيت لفيت ورجعت للرياضه وعملت
[موسيقى]
رياضيين يمثلوا بلدانهم هم احسن ممثل
للبلدان اللي هم ينتميونها الرياضه عالم
كبير وشيسع جدا فلما درست التجاره كنت
حابه افهم
الصيد الاخر للرياضه مش بس كرياضيه وبعد
كملت التخصص في يعني اللي دخلت فيه في عمق
يعني في الرياضه وحاولت اني اعرفها من
نواحي الكل
[موسيقى]
اول ميدالين ذكرها تحصلت عليها كانت في
المئه متر سباحه على صدر في البطوله
التونسيه يعني هي البطوله الوطنيه
التونسيه وكنت انا صغيره وكنت اشارك مع
الكبار لكن ايسنك يعني اقرب ميداليه هي
الميداليات اللي ربحتهم في 2019 في بطوله
العالم للماستر لانه يعني شاركت بطوله
العالم من الماستر هذه بعد ما كان جاتني
اصابه بعد لما رحت وشاركت في بطوله العالم
وجبت يعني 4 ميداليه ذهبيه وميداليه
برونزيه كانت حسيتها
مختلفه يعني
الميداليات اللي ربهم كانوا بعض التعب
وكانوا بعض احباط وكان
فاحساسهم كان كان غير
[موسيقى]
كل عمر وعنده صعوبات وكل فتره وعندها
صعوباتها خصوصا اني انا يعني انتقلت
لفرنسا لما كان عمري 15 سنه فيمكن صعوبه
الاولى اني تفرقت على اهلي وعلى عائلتي
وعلى اخواني انا البنت الوحيده في البيت
فكنت دلوله ماما وبابا واخواتي فلما رحت
لفرنسا ممكن كانت اول صعوبه واجهتها اني
لقيت نفسي وحدي بس هو كان هدفي اني اتحسن
واطور من نفسي واوصل للاهدافي في رياضه
السباحه بعد الصعوبات تتطور مع العمر يكون
في صعوبات اخرى ممكن من ابرزها يعني احنا
في الرياضه في الرياضيين في عنا اصابات
يعني تجينا اصابات والمهم مش انك يعني
تحاول ترجع بسرعه بعض الاصابات بس انك
تاخد وقتك ويعني تدوي نفسك وتعمل لي علاج
طبيعي وبعد ترجع يعني ترجع في الوقت اللي
لازم ترجع فيه لا قبل ولا بعد فكان عندي
يعني على مسيره الرياضيه كما كانوا عندي
برشا اصاباتي
في رياضه الدراجات لاني بعض السباحه
انتقلت لرياضه اللي هي سباحه ودراجات
وجايه
فاول ما بديت الرياضه وين عازمه اني افضل
رياضه كنت خارجه يعني العب سايكنج قبل
البطوله اول بطوله اللي كنت مفروض اشارك
فيها وضربتني سياره وكسر لي كتفي يعني
اخرت دخولي رياض
سنه ونص
[موسيقى]
ابرز اسباب نجاحي احول كل ما اطيح احاول
ارجع وابني من اول وجديد يعني المهم مش
انك يعني
انك توصل بسرعه للهدف بس لانه اي حد بيكون
بيواجه صعوبات يعني
بس اهم شيء انك لما تطيح تعرف تقف يعني مش
تسلم وتنزلي يدك تحت وتقول خلاص يعني انا
انتهيت ولا يعني مش راح اوصل للهدف بتاعي
صراحه الشعور الكل يعني والترشح
للاولمبياد ويعني مشيتي للقلام كان يعني
كان التجربه من نوع اخر يعني حتى قد ما
شاركت في بطولات عالم وفي بطولات يعني من
انواع الكل لكن الالعاب الاولمبيه تبقى هي
من نوع خاص يعني طعمها خاص
ستراس اللي فيها يعني قبل السباق اللي
تكون وتكون حاسس انك
كامله يعني والمنافسه كانت اخويا فيها
يعني
الترشح لها صعب يعني الوصول للالعاب
الاولمبيه في حد ذاته انجاز والحمد لله
يعني لما وصلت للعمل الاولمبيه اوكي ما
حققتش اللي انا كنت اتمنى حقو لانه للاسف
يعني صارت لي ظروف صحيه قبلها بالضبط ممكن
ولا مره تكلمت عليها يعني بس كانت ظروف
يعني كنت يعني ممكن اروح فيها يعني اني
اموت حتى بس الحمد لله يعني كوني روح
الاولمبيه وشاركت ومثل تونس في الالعاب
الاولمبيه يعني
الوصول الاولمبيات هو ممكن للرياضيين الكل
هدف من اللي يعني لما حد يدخل يمارس
الرياضه من اللي هو صغير يكون هدفه
الاولمبياد لو هي رياضه اولمبيه
فالاولمبياد المفروض يكون هو الهدف الابعد
طويل المدى بس للوصول للاولمبياد انا بنصح
يعني الرياضيين واللي هما وصلوا اللي هم
ممكن ينافسوا يترشحوا الاولمبياد انهم
يكون عندهم اهداف يعني الاهداف القريبه
والمتوسطه المدى والبعيده المدى لانه انت
مش ممكن اليوم دخلت تتمرن واليوم بديت
الرياضه في اي رياضه كانت وتقول خلاص انا
بعد اربع سنوات بروح الاولمبيكس انصحهم
انهم يكونوا يكونوا واقعيين في في
طموحاتهم في اهدافهم بس ما يكون ما ينزلوش
من انفسهم بعد بس الهدف لازم يكون صعب
المنال وصعب انك توصل له وتحاول انك توصل
له باهداف ثانويه بصراحه يعني انا يعني
حاليا ما بشاركش في البطولات الميداليات
ولا لاني اطلع على اي شيء لا هدفي اني
يعني اخلي الناس تؤمن بانفسها وخصوصا يعني
البنات والاولاد الصغار انهم يؤمنوا
بانفسهم ويعرفوا انهم ممكن يوصلوا
الاهدافهم فانا بس نقول لهم يعني حطوا
اهدافكم وما تخليوش اي حد يعني
يحبطكم ويقول لكم انكم مش قادرين لانه اي
حد قادر يعني احنا
كبشر ربي خلقنا انه ممكن نعمله حاجات احنا
بنفسنا يعني ما نخيلوش قدرتنا وقوتنا بس
انك لما تعمل الحاجه وتحولها ذات انك تعرف
اذا انت قادر ولا لا بس اذا انت من برا
وتتفرج وتحاول انك تعمل وتقول انا ممكن مش
راح انفع في الرياضه هذه ولا مش راح يعني
امنطق لا انت مش عارف الا اذا جربت وحاولت
وجربت وحاولت وبعد ان شاء الله يعني
يجيبوا